in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Ben and
Jetton are with us hey guys how are you
how are you welcome welcome where do you
guys live Houston Texas fine and you're
here to do your debt-free scream yes sir
I love it
and how much have you guys paid off
almost 28,000 to us sorry $228,000 a
little difference yeah
okay and how long did this take you
about 23 months whoa
making what kind of money during this
time we started out at 85,000 in the
years up to about 130 now Wow what do
you guys do for a living I'm an ER nurse
I'm a flight paramedic okay very cool so
that's a lot of debt and it's in a short
period of time is that a house you sold
or something or what we did I got a new
job down in Houston we sold our house
okay I know what the devil what did the
house sell for
oh gosh to 210 yeah 210 okay and and the
rest of the debt was what Oh a couple of
credit cards a personal loan my student
loan a couple of cars so what made you
decide when you sold the house and and
above that to really attack this for 23
months
tell me the story what happened two
years ago well she had been telling me
that we need to get on a budget for a
while and she was tired of doing all the
finances and that me being you know
stubborn about not doing it mm-hmm so
she passed it off to me and one day on
my way to my second job I heard you on
the radio and I texted her that night
said we're gonna do this and get out of
debt Wow she was all about it so I you
hand it off to him he starts listening
radio chatter on he comes home with this
new great idea which is the idea you had
all along listen to me classic classic
wife he made it his idea right yeah I
love it good good wifing that's good so
what did you say when he came back in
and said you walks in the house and goes
we're gonna do this I said great why
haven't you listened to me the four
years ago there you go I love it that's
perfect good answer
okay and so you decide you're gonna get
out of debt you decide you're gonna get
on a plan and in the midst of that then
you take a new job huh I did at the end
of that 23 months we were gonna we had a
plan we were gonna be a debt-free
everything but the house in 24 months
but you know
wanted to try something new and got a
new job and ended up having to move for
it sold the house and that just helped
us finish everything off anyways and
gave us our six month emergency fund and
knocked us all the way through the
coulomb an ER nurse says there's always
a shortage so you can jump anywhere
right pretty much yeah very cool well
good for you guys
so you're renting right now we are and
you have no debt in the world right
congratulations think how's that feel
it's pretty weird how long have you guys
been married six years six years and so
Jetton how did this change your marriage
once he decided he's going to get on
board and you guys are doing this stuff
together it helped our communication it
helped also I was like hey why didn't
you listen to me he said he'd start
listening me anymore but it'sit's
actually helped because now he's kind of
understood it from a different
perspective and where I've been coming
from if you get that solved let all the
other wives know how you did it okay at
the beginning I was doing everything and
he would ask for money I'm like we don't
have it and he kept saying well why not
I have a good job well we don't and he
didn't understand and I was tired of
being his mom and telling him no so I
said okay well here you go there you go
I'm stressed I can't do this anymore you
do it he started doing it and he
realized that we really didn't have as
much money as he thought we had and it
helped considerably having him involved
in it and not just being one-sided but
having us both be a part of the plan
yeah hey man so when people find out
you've paid off all of your debt and
they ask how did you do that what do you
tell them the secret to getting out of
debt is sticking to it is because there
are hard times where just you get
exhausted that we were both working two
to three jobs she would ask when we're
debt-free can we play more you know and
so it just got real hard cuz you want to
play with your kid they're only young
once but you know you just persevere now
now we can yeah you live like no one
else later you can live like no one else
now how old is she what's your name for
is is Caitlyn Caitlyn does four alright
very cool she's the reason we came here
she wanted to see Dave and give Dave a
hug
I will come out of commercial break and
make that happen
yeah we had to show a girl I love it
that's fun very very fun well
congratulations you guys how's it feel
any payments awesome although it's kind
of annoying to pay rent and we're
excited about building up and saving for
our house now it's nice putting that
money away for us and not giving it just
sending it off cuz right those big
checks at the end of the month to pay
that debt was it was just hard to write
that check but now I just transfer that
money into a savings account now it to
my money or our money you know so it's
nice now
very cool congratulations you guys very
well done alright Ben and Jetton Houston
Texas two hundred and twenty eight
thousand dollars paid off in twenty
three months making eighty five now
making a hundred and thirty that
includes the sale with their two hundred
ten thousand dollar house but twenty
three months of tough budgeting to so
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream three
[Applause]
all ready to go you guys that's fabulous
very very very well done
[Music]